if you're lucky in love this Valentine's
Day you may have your adolescent
friendships to thank for it a study
showed that the quality of friendships
you establish as a teenager are the
foundation for healthy romantic
relationships when you're an adult a Pew
Research Center survey found 78% of
teenagers say they have 1 to 5 close
friends
98% say they have at least one that's
good at least one is good Lisa d'amour
is the author of the best-selling book
under pressure confronting the epidemic
of stress and anxiety in girls and she's
also a CBS News contributor and
adolescent psychologist good morning
good morning happy Valentine's Day Happy
Valley
so walk us through this connection
between your relationships as a teenager
and your love life as an adult so this
is a really cool study because what they
did is they tracked 200 people from ages
13 to 30 mm-hmm and they looked at what
was going on in their friendships as
teenagers and how that predicted to the
quality of their love lives as adults
and what they found was that the kids
who expected their relationships to be
of high quality could stand up for
themselves and could make and keep
friends were the ones who went on to
have really satisfying love lives in
adulthood and we're talking about
platonic relationships in high school
automatic ones in adulthood yeah and
what we think is there's a lot that you
learn in these close platonic
friendships you learn how to be intimate
you learn how to manage conflict and
then over time you learn sort of how to
make a commitment to someone maturity
that comes with sticking with a
friendship you have to go into these
friendships with a certain set of skills
or do you learn them in the friendship
well I don't think we know that but what
was so cool about this study is that
they actually looked at the marks we
want to see kids hit along the way yeah
so at 13 what we want to see is that
kids expect to be treated well and that
they treat others well so parents are
really kind of coach kids into the idea
of you know don't tolerate meanness in
your friendships and then use
assertiveness not aggression or being
passive when you're upset at 15 and 16
we really wanted to see the kids had
friends and sustained friendships you
know there's a lot of drama 7th through
9th grade yes
that should die down by 10 through 11th
grade
see the kids have really found their
people so if you've got a 10th or 11th
grader who's not really able to make a
good connection with someone like take
that seriously both for the immediate
term and also the longer term and then
at 17 and 18 what we saw is that we
wanted to see kids really have strong
and sustained relationships
really kind of a committed friendship
over time why is that non sexual
intimacy for teens so important to learn
well so the cool thing here is that you
want to see intimacy without the glue of
a physical relationship you know so
often that's what holds things together
what other stuff isn't working well yeah
but when teenagers can say to someone
you know I feel close to you and then
the researchers found that the friends
said oh I feel close back to you you
know that that was actually a sign of
really having the skills they needed to
carry on into a more meaningful
relationship down the line and what
you're suggesting here is is also that
the parents play a really big role in
giving them initial skills but also in
supporting them along the way absolutely
and I think especially for teenagers you
know you want to have romances you feel
like oh I wish I had a boyfriend every
witch had a girlfriend so one thing
parents can do today is if you're
teenagers in the Lonely Hearts Club
today I think you can say to them don't
worry about it it does not have anything
to do with how things are gonna be down
the line focus on your friendships focus
on being a good friend choosing good
friends this is what will set you up for
the future very good advice all right
Lisa's the more thank you very much a
happy Valentine's Day under pressure
confronting the epidemic of stress and
anxiety and girls is available in
paperback right now